hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and with me is
Gemma
[Music]
Ambrose in the background and Cordelia
you know say hi Cordelia good deal yeah
all right so anyway my kids are all here
well not all of them there's another one
upstairs I have four but today we're
gonna continue to work on this Expo
react native app so right now we're
running it as a as a web app so Kevin
Bacon's in the channel who works at Expo
and does some awesome stuff with Expo
web we are going to see some Expo web
stuff that's let me bring this up on the
screen let's see where it went
[Music]
there we go my computer went into sleep
mode and so all my all my screens got
rearranged so I had it all set up and
then I lost it there we go all right so
this is the app running actually it's
not it's not really running it's just
whatever is left over from what we ran
last last evening
what do you hold enough inverse make a
side hey this is not a Gatorade
commercial all right so anyway I'm
running react native with Expo and let's
see if the chat sums up with my chat if
somebody try to type something in the
chat because I think my chat got
disconnected and I'll see if I can see
it because right now I am NOT able to
see the messages in the chat I could try
to
open it in a new window okay
I open my chat in a new window and now I
can see the messages so hopefully this
will work okay yeah so I think I lost
some of the first messages so if you
asked me something right off the bat
then I probably can't see it anymore but
I can see the chat now so hey everybody
I guess it was really weird there were
only like three messages in the chat and
that's very uncommon
so I def lost the first few messages or
whatever so sorry about that but anyway
I am I built this like built the app
with Expo which is a tool that helps you
build with react native so I'm using
yarn so I just typed in yarn start and
now once expo runs and does its thing if
I hit W it'll open up the expo app in a
web browser so you can see here having
the web browser I can refresh so it's
running here which is pretty sweet and
it actually makes it way easier
Kadir you don't hit that button you
can't sit with me alright
they're in buttons so it's it's actually
really awesome I kind of prefer working
like this unless there's something I
really need to test on a mobile phone I
prefer to do most of the development
with the web version of of Expo which is
using react native web it's just so much
easier to be able to do all your
debugging with like in a web app right
the the feedback loop is tighter
alright so it's there's less time I you
know the there's a little bit of lag if
you're developing like on a mobile
device connected to your computer
between when you make a change and what
it actually updates on the device I find
like
I just have way less issues doing it
like this I do have to frequently kind
of keep the mobile version open though
just to make sure I haven't messed
anything up but it definitely helps me
develop faster this is I've used this
professionally and on side projects like
I'm the one here so definitely I like
that that aspect of it and trying to get
my there we go
want to get my chat all situated with
the stream data on my other screen here
okay cool
so this is the third stream that we've
done with this particular app real quick
I'm gonna go over the goal of this app
we are trying to take data from a
brain-computer interface which I'll put
on in just a minute and I'll show you
but there's a company called neuro City
that makes a brain-computer interface
that's called the notion it's it reads
your brainwaves and then it has an
interface JavaScript interface that you
can use to get that data into your app
so that's what we're gonna do and for
this particular app for phase one of the
app all I want to do is measure my level
of focus and then display a warning
whenever my focus has dropped to low
just to kind of remind me to stay
focused what do you put in your mouth so
that's the goal now in this particular
stream what we want to do is we pretty
much did most of the work we needed to
persist user data from one session to
another and we want to keep basically we
want to just finish that we are almost
finished we had kind of a little bug
with it at the end so I want to finish
that and then actually put in our
threshold
for the the focus so like we're gonna
figure out like at what level of focus
should be sure warning and what should
that warning be and it's probably gonna
be a different warning on the web as
opposed to on on mobile naked you can't
all sit on my lap so why don't you go
play
that's for camera oh yeah don't press
those buttons it links up to my phone
via bluetooth but if you're gonna be
down there you can't interrupt me okay
so alright let's see so here's how we're
gonna do this in the stream I'm gonna
start a timer or Pomodoro timer it's
gonna go for 25 minutes during that time
about 25 minutes I'm not really gonna
look at the chat too much and we try to
focus on coding and explaining what I'm
coding and then after the timer goes up
I'm gonna take a break I'm gonna go to
the chat and I'm gonna answer all your
questions I want to try to keep this
stream to just about an hour long and
because I want to try to get the kids to
bed help get the kids to bed so you
wanna say something
Jemma would like to say so I'm not to
get the coronavirus yeah it's very good
yeah Jemma Jemma doesn't want anyone to
get the coronavirus so be safe alright
you want to say something to everybody
gets to say one thing and then you gotta
let me code alright don't die alright
Jemma says don't get the current virus
amber says don't die
Cordelia would you like to say anything
she can do twirls all by herself
alright cool all right now say something
now you gotta be quiet let me do the
coding okay
all the people all the people want to
see the coding part okay
what Jemma when you get older you can
have a youtube channel too right all
right and actually so Jemma has been
working on free code camp lessons to
learn how to code and Ambrose has been
working on coding to kindergarten math
yes we're good I told him he had to
learn how to read he had to learn his
math all right so see you later date
should being on the show I'll see you in
about I'll see you in about an hour be
good okay all right so anyway I hope I
hope you all right with that
I thought is when you work with kids I
don't really have an office I'm just in
my basement so the kids can just come
down whenever so let's get started I'm
gonna start my timer
[Music]
make sure it's actually working on
yesterday's show I started a timer and
then somehow I stopped it and so it
looks like it's running successfully
this time all right cool
let me make this bigger I'll make sure
everybody can see all right I'm gonna
make this as small as I can I'm gonna
get rid of these files on the side I did
put this on github so if you check the
description for this video there's a
link to the github repo so you can see
all this code and I guess it's not gonna
be that useful to you unless you have an
ocean headset but you can at least check
out see what we're doing get a kind of a
closer look at the code but what we want
to do is the next step I guess we want
to do is let the user can put in their
ID email and password and that links
them up to the brain computer interface
and it gets us data but as soon as we
refresh the page they lose their their
subscription to the device as soon as
you put the ID and we can get it again
but what I want to do is save the ID in
local storage so that they don't even
have to put the idea in again it'll just
check local storage and so we already
have the code for that in here so we
have this this get item four and we're
gonna get the device ID right but the
problem is the window part where we
actually save is not working right now
uh-huh
so we want to figure out where we can
make this save so the reason it's not
working is I think I think that this
function is actually running first and
we're gonna test that let's test that
because I don't think we really have
I'm just gonna do a console.log here and
just console.log some some nonsense just
to see if that is in fact what's
happening and let's make what's suspect
we'll bring up the console and I want to
see if that's really the issue that's
happening here because I'm not convinced
that it is and let me get my data yeah
this is it have you turned my device on
so this is the neuro City notion headset
if you want to know more about this
headset and how it works you can go to
you can check out a video I did on my
youtube channel the link to my youtube
channel is in the description below I
talk a lot more about what this headset
can do and give you it like a demo so
alright that's going to start up it's
just going to take a few seconds to
start and then we'll should be able to
connect in the meantime let me type in
our data
[Music]
okay so this is actually running every
time something changes which is what I
thought it was that what's happening so
what's gonna happen now is if I put a
password in this is gonna run and I
believe it's gonna try to log us in so
what I'm gonna do is let's just remove
password from here so this doesn't run
when a password is entered it's gonna
erase my stuff but I'll just copy it
again and let's verify yeah see so
password is not running here so this is
going to test my theory to see if it was
actually this function that was logging
us in early it was basically were
getting logged in to early like before
we press the button to login
let's probably change that to login
instead of press me but remember to do
that in a minute okay so grab the
password alright sweet so it was this
function that was automatically logging
us in so just by removing password I
think we've solved that issue and now
when I hit this this button should call
this init function which should first
save our device ID to async storage so
let's go to our application and go to
local storage and see right now we don't
have the device ID sage when I hit this
button the device ID should be saved and
we should get logged in which yep all
right so the notions online that's one
of the double check so sweet so we have
our device ID and now let me make this
bigger so I can see all right so we can
see we have our device ID now saved and
we are connected so we're just we're
getting some random data since this
isn't actually on my
head so we're not getting real data yet
but sweet so I think that's gonna be an
easy fix then so we have the data so
what should happen now is if I log out
no that's not if i refresh the page
which should happen is that it should
check as soon as this this component
which is our app component mounts it
should check to see if we have device ID
in a Singh storage and if it does it'll
set the device ID when the device ID
gets set it should trigger this function
right which should set in motion
everything we need to stay logged in so
let's see if that is really the case
it's refresh hey all right cool so we
saw like briefly a little flash of the
the login panel until everything
actually ran which is fine and now we're
still focused so awesome that was
actually like that was really easy I
ended the stream without having fixed
that and it was literally what like a
five minute fix so that's really cool so
since we we kind of fixed that issue I'm
gonna go ahead and commit this before we
move on the next step is gonna be
figuring out how to display a
notification I'm just always used to
doing a get status just to make sure of
what's changed even though we really
only are editing one file here so let's
do git commit and I'm gonna do an AM
flag that means it's gonna add so it's a
git add plus a commit with a message and
so whatever I put in this message is
will be our commit message so I'm gonna
say feet for feature and
we're gonna say let's see login login
persists through page refresh okay cool
so that's the new feature that we've
added and I'm gonna get push since it's
pretty much just me working on this
project right now I'm just pushing
straight to master it's still a test
project if this was really in production
and there were more people working on it
I would probably set up different
branches and then do a pull request but
I think gets a little bit of overkill
for a side project right now alright so
now we have that set up not only did we
really want that set up but also it's
going to help us develop this a lot more
quickly because we won't have to keep
logging in which is a little bit of a
pain in the last two streams so now we
need to I guess we need to keep track of
our focus the number of our focus so
let's see how we're doing that right now
yeah so we have our focus here in our on
our state so since every time our focus
changes it changes state so we're going
to be able to pretty much track that
right and we can come down here and say
[Music]
within this
[Music]
and let's let's go to our Styles should
we do styles yeah yeah I think that
would be a good way to do it right now
our background color let me do this I'm
gonna move my styles into my function
because that's gonna allow me to have
access to the state right and then now
for background color we can make it
determine our based on on the focus
level so let's say focus if focus is
less than and let's say less than I
don't know
Oh point three then we want the
background color to be let's just say
red for now so that'll be easy to see
otherwise we want the background color
to be white let's see that works there
we go so you can see every time the
focus falls below 0.3 it's red
[Music]
and then we go above it it's it's white
now like I said right now I don't even
have the headset on so it's just kind of
giving us like your random numbers
because there's not real data coming in
I could try to put this on so we could
get some real data I don't know how well
I'm gonna be able to focus while I'm
kind of working on oops well I'm doing
the stream and everything but I'm gonna
try try my best yeah
[Music]
okay I might have to drop the focus
level if I ever want to get out of the
red here
let's drop it down to a point - and then
that way we'll get there we go so right
now this is like a decent indicator what
I would really like though is maybe
something a little bit
[Music]
oops
it doesn't like that I was using Styles
before I declared it so it's let's put
this up here a little bit I don't think
I'm actually even uding using this
loading this is maybe leftover from yeah
I think that's leftover
[Music]
from the kind of boilerplate stuff I
brought in at first
[Music]
all right so sweet now what I'd like to
do is have I guess some type of
[Music]
notification pop-up and maybe have it
like vibrate really ultimately it would
be nice if the user could pick their
choice of how to be alerted like what
type of alarm they would want but you
know for now this at least gives us some
indication of our focus level that's
that's very bright and obvious but we
would have to kind of be looking at our
phone so it's not not really ideal right
if you're trying to focus on something
and then you don't really want to be
looking at your phone right so we need
some sort of notification that is going
to get your attention even if you're
focused on something else so I think
some type of audible or like vibration
would be best now we can't really do a
vibration on you know on our web version
of this but we could at least put in
some of the code for it and then test it
out right okay so let's go into either
we're gonna look either in the expo
documentation or react native so first
I'm gonna look at react native and see
if we have something for vibrate
vibration cool so we do have an API for
vibration suite vibration dot vibrate
all right cool you can see that we can
also check and see what Expo has I think
it's expo dot IO yeah here's I have the
dachshund here the vibration I just want
to see if Expo has anything different
but it looks like they have the same the
same dog here so that's good
occasionally Expo will have like some
extra things
extra extra components that make it a
little bit easier to work with these
device things but for now this is gonna
work so let's just see if we can set it
up so that we have this you know
vibration happen based on a state change
so first let's pull in vibration from
react native and it looks like we need
to add something to our
androidmanifest.xml so let's do that add
this in and this looks like a permission
thing so let's say we need to get
permission to to use the vibrate feature
I need to see if we even have I don't
know that we even have this because we
haven't attempted to run this yeah we've
only done the web so we may have to
attempt to run this first so let's see I
believe we can try to do an Android
build if we just type a yep there we go
let's see what we have it may not work I
don't have an Android studio installed
so I may have to get that installed and
then try it on a different stream and
Lily Android device phone oh okay
I can I need to connect my Android
device which I can do
and this left my cord that I mean bicoid
I left my cord in my bag that's in the
closet upstairs so it's cool I'm gonna
drop into my Amazon Alexa device that's
upstairs in my house and have one of my
kids bring me my bag and then we can
connect my device up to the computer so
let's do a drop in this is probably the
most useful thing on on Amazon so it's
hello hello can you hear me yep
there's anybody up there hey I need to I
need a favor
can somebody go in the closet and get my
backpack and bring it down to me please
hello hey can can you go in my backpack
and get in my closet and get my backpack
and bring down to me please all right
thank you all right cool so when I get
my cord to hook up my android phone I
should be able to run this on my Android
phone and we should be able to test out
the vibration on my phone which would be
pretty cool I'll just like hold it up to
the camera I guess you could see it
running which is not ideal but I don't
know that we can test the vibration
to simulate hi said to come down with my
backpack
you came down empty-handed oh you just
came to get my my drone alright I don't
have any gum in here I don't think I do
I just need to score actually I do have
gum here here's your old word you can
have my pack of gum I shut the door on
your way out please thanks
ok so I've got the cord and made sure I
brought this
I normally use this when I'm at work but
I made sure to bring it home because I I
figured I might need it this is like the
longest normal USB to USB Secord that I
have I need to find a port for it I
don't know if it's like this for you all
but like all my USB ports are always
taken up
I don't realize this but I actually have
a USBC port on that computer that's
awesome I can connect it just through
USB C so that's pretty sweet so now I am
connected and let's try this again I'm
gonna run this yeah sweet we're running
the application on the pixel XL and this
should be I might have to scan this
barcode if I can find it
let's go over here see if I can find it
here so if I scan this barcode I should
be able to to run this on the phone I
need to find my expo app and scan this
QR code it's still it's running the last
application that I built on here not the
new one so I need to see what is why is
it doing this now usually if you shake
the phone you can come up with a screen
like a screen will come up but it's not
working
there we go I know that didn't work
you see this is really weird don't if I
could do anything from here
so like just you can see it is it's
gonna be really hard for you to see but
it's running an application right now
but this is the last application that I
worked on in Expo so it's definitely not
what I what I want let's see how I'm
gonna check my timer because I may be at
a time for yeah okay so it's almost time
for me to stop and go to the questions
but then also I need to know enable
drive area it's a developer menu so I
can statistic command and I'll do a TV
show input key event in my terminal
window shake device vertically a bit
yeah my shaking of my device is just not
not working I could try to reload
yeah reloading is still coming up with
the old one alright since I can run this
I've never tried this one before
I don't know where to see if I run it
here nope hmm
yeah so an Android device can run it
here but it's not
you might actually need to get the
Android emulator going if this if I
can't get it to work all right
I'm gonna take a little break though
anyway and answer some questions so
maybe I'll I'll figure some way out my
subconscious will work on this problem
while I'm reading questions so I'm
scrolling up as far as I can remember I
missed a few a few questions they got
cut off from the chat at the beginning
so apologies if I missed your question
but let's see
so nds this brain computer app what is
its function the function of this
particular app is to give me an alert
give the user an alert whenever their
level of focus has dropped below a
certain threshold no stock says what
technology is using for the actual brain
computer interface it is this device
that I'm wearing it is called the notion
headset by neuro City it's a the a brain
computer so inside here there there is
actually a small computer very similar
similar to what you would have in your
cell phone it's an Internet of Things
device and it's really like very
lightweight and just fits fits right on
your head it's adjustable so it can fit
you know a variety of different head
sizes so that's the device I'm using if
you want to know more about that check
out my youtube channel links in the
description I do a demo video where I
talk a lot more about the device in
particular you also if you do a search
for neuro City trying to think what the
with the website is I got the website up
it's it's neuro City Co n EU ro s ity
dot C oh and you can sign up to I
believe right now you can pre-order the
headset but check check out the site
you'll be able to see how how you can
maybe get the
the brain computer interface err rude
sorry for mispronouncing your name says
you are my favorite
I believe it's trying to say channel
thank you I appreciate that and I assume
you mean free code camp channel which
has a lot more than just me on it and so
it's not like I'm just your favorite but
I appreciate it
free code camp does a lot of good good
stuff see see a lot of you just saying
hi so hey everybody
let's see yusuf says the best channel
with best lecturer oh thank you I
appreciate that
you got greetings from all over the
world here looks like someone's saying
hi from Ghana someone from Panama
awesome Leonard asks where do you live -
your kids also at school so I actually
live in Ohio but I'm very close to
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and that's where
I work I'm right on the border and my
kids they don't have school so they
never have school on a Sunday like a
Saturday or Sunday but they actually
have school off because of the
coronavirus school has been cancelled in
in the whole state of Ohio for the next
three weeks so I've actually shut down
quite a few things there's no there's a
limit on a thing like any gatherings
above 100 people are now banned the they
I think they just said they're gonna
shut down all restaurants and bars
although they're allowing like drive
throughs and delivery and like take-out
food so there's a lot of restrictions
now in Ohio which is probably for the
best right from what I understand you
know this if we can try to do as much as
we can as early as we can to stop the
virus then you know more people will be
healthy but yeah we'll be we'll all be
here together in the house for a long
time Sergey says are they your web team
yeah not yet but I'm training them one
day though I'm gonna train them up of a
whole team of programmers that Val dark
says this seems like something that
might be useful for not quite self
driving cars considering the only death
so far but from people thinking the car
was fully self-driving yeah actually
what I'd like to do with this is run it
as an Android Auto app so that could
remind the driver to stay focused in
so whenever the driver loses focus it
would give them some sort of
notification that wouldn't be too
distracting but would remind them to
like focus on driving so that's going to
be like one of the next steps after we
get the basics of this app working is I
really want to try to use it with with
the Android auto and I'm because I have
an Android phone I can test it out with
Android auto but you know ideally I know
you know there are other so like Apple I
think has their version I've never used
it but I think it could potentially help
prevent accidents in in cars if I can
get it to work see
Leonard says here in Germany we have
three weeks.3 of school due to
coronavirus plus two weeks Easter
holidays for five weeks no school okay
so this is yeah I imagine there's
probably quite a few people out there
they're in a similar situation where
school has been cancelled or you know
you're working from home or you know
something like that
I hear that Italy is pretty much on
lockdown I don't know if anybody's from
Italy watching the stream you know let
us know how it is at least from what I
can get here it's just you know online
so I prefer to try to get information
from people who are actually there as
opposed to like the news I feel like
it's kind of more authentic information
and not filtered through you know
whatever news source but anyway I'm
gonna go my timer went up for for the
chat so I'm gonna go back to a little
bit of code and then I'll come back to
the chat in a little bit and see what's
see what's going on in the chat answer
some questions looks like loose in China
somebody in here said that hello from
China hey how's it going so we were just
talking about the corona virus with
being from China like how is it there in
terms of like you know are you is it at
this point do you feel like it's pretty
contained or is there still a lot like
it's that you can't do it is it's
starting it feels kind of like all over
here
at this point I think it'll get worse
than it is now in the United States in
China do you feel like it's gonna get
worse or does it seem like it's getting
better anyway oh wait I I may not see
your message for a while cuz I'm gonna
go back to the chat but I just kind of
would would love to get like a
first-hand account of kind of what we're
feeling you get about it I realized
China is a very big country so different
areas of China are gonna have have
different
effects from from the virus but it's
still good to get somebody you know
somebody that's there get kind of their
account of it let's see let's go back to
all right here so I'm gonna give what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna completely quit
at the expo app and go back in and see
if I can get the new app to load and
let's skin is me going here okay
unfortunately it's still the old app I'm
gonna try to do a little shake I guess
this is supposed to work I don't know
why it's not working do I not have I
don't
yeah I don't understand what it's not
working okay um so unfortunately I can't
get the developer menu to load so I may
have to check out Android studio like
I'm not gonna try to do the install for
Android studio right now so we may just
have to
I'm gonna try to run this I mean I
really don't think yes I didn't think
that would work okay and this it looks
like these directions are assuming that
we're running on a Mac so it may be that
I just can't use these instructions for
a Windows machine let me see
I'm just want to check the chat really
quick to see if anybody put the if
anybody had any idea how I could get to
see refresh looks like
okay let's see alright so I guess we
need just do a quick Google search right
because if we can't test the the
features on a mobile device then we're
gonna be a little bit stuck here so let
me say all right well let's just open up
a few of them open up your simulator
[Music]
says I can press ctrl M let's see what
that eye looks like that is not working
wonder if I can if I change the mode
that doesn't really do anything
oh yeah we have some messages here
mm-hmm I don't think that works okay the
only thing I can think of if I do a save
will that trigger looks like it's only
triggering a web refresh
okay let me go back to here
all right so control-m did not work
development note enabled I believe we do
but let's double check make sure we have
dev mode enabled yep we do make sure I
double check yep we turned off
production mode so it is dead mode
I just hit our to restart Metro bundler
just to see if I would do anything which
it did not it okay alright let's try
this one refresh
let's see this one too I don't think
that's gonna help sorry I'm just trying
I'm not reading this out loud I'm trying
to skim through first to see if these
are even like close to what what we're
experiencing this looks like Android
studio so that's not what we what we
want okay let's see I'm gonna try to
change something in here and see if they
if saving it would would do anything so
I guess probably the easiest thing to
change would be some text so let's add
in an extra space see if we get an
update hmm looks like nothing I didn't
see anything on the screen you know this
this is still updating you know we could
try to do I could try to just completely
quit and then start it up again see if
we can get a difference with the you
know total restart
and we can press a to run the Android
emulator let's see what we have see what
other commands we have so
our current mode is development mode
which is good that's what it needs to be
let's do shift R because that should
restart and clear the cache maybe that
would help shift maybe this will help
alright while that's running I'm gonna
go to the chat and see what's what's
going on in the chat here
oh cool so alex is in the chat and he's
one of the founders of neuro City it's
the company that makes this this headset
and he said that the the gamma
brainwaves are what determines your
focus so the higher your gamma brainwave
the higher your focus that's pretty cool
William says I'm running Python our API
is the equivalent to modules um I I
think API is pretty standard no matter
what the language is so I'm not exactly
sure in Python
what module means but I don't think it
would be the equivalent of an API if
anybody's is more knowledgeable about
Python though please please let us know
mr. own said I love this awesome thank
you
JP game says is your job stressful I
wouldn't really say my job is stressful
it right now the project that I'm
working on is still like in development
so we're not really there's not a lot
that's dependent on our project yet
that's gonna change once we start like
releasing two more locations so it will
get a little bit more stressful but
right now it's it's not it's not too bad
programming I'd say in general in itself
is not stressful but depending on what
project you're working on and what's at
stake with the project it could be
stressed like there are external factors
that could be stressful alright so this
thing's still still doing its thing
which is fine because it gives me time
to catch up on the chat SSD you asked if
I could explain what I'm doing
looks like somebody else answered in the
chat so so thank you for for answering
it
JP Games asks what's your favorite
musical actor group uh I don't know if I
could do a favorite I like a lot of
different kinds of music I don't really
know if I have like a favorite yeah I
don't know I'd have to think about it
that's crazy that I never thought about
that yeah I don't know what my favorite
would be Mostafa asked if I stream about
react Jes yeah I do
streams with react yes so right now I'm
more focusing on react native that's
what I work with more frequently but I
have done streams that are just normal
react and I'll probably end up doing
some normal react stuff as as well
Daniel says I'm from Brazil would have a
cousin that lives in Ohio around Ava oh
okay that's awesome
cool Kevin's from California okay Daniel
says a Avon Lake okay I'm not really
sure where he won Lake is to tell you
truth I'm not originally from Ohio I'm
from West Virginia so I don't like I've
lived in
I started to get a little bit of lag I
don't know if it's from this running or
the internet is messed up
it looks like the stream is still okay
so let me know if there's anything wrong
with the stream and I think we're good
but my my mouth's rose up for a minute
there a progress Salim is from Israel
welcome there's someone else from Cali
to summer from Vancouver Canada actually
I love we have people from all over for
these streams they'll fail dog says how
much have you researched about brain
computer interfaces I haven't done a ton
of research myself I'm interested in it
and you know I'll read articles when I
see him but I haven't I wouldn't say
that I'm an expert you know at all my
main work is in using javascript mostly
react to build you know apps so I'm not
really a brain computer interface
researcher but more of just kind of like
dude I'm into it as a hobby like I I see
it as something that could be really
awesome and helpful for a lot of people
that you know I'd like to do more with
whenever I can kind of like just on the
side bulat says my school is closed for
a month gym is closed as well trying to
learn react native with Jesse awesome
well hopefully you learned something
that stinks I know a lot of the gyms are
closed I I like to go to the gym and
workout that's gonna be kind of hard I
was I told my kids earlier that I'm
gonna start using them as weights and
doing squats with him or something
because I can't go to the gym I think I
don't know if all the gyms around where
I am are closed yet or not I don't know
for sure but probably probably not a
great idea you go to the gym although
there are some gems that are open 24
hours a day and I kind of wonder like if
I went there like very very early in the
morning
you know could I get in and be like the
only person in there you know that might
work
[Music]
see this is there been any progress on
this thing
let's I'm gonna close out some of these
screens here I'm gonna stop that and
maybe try it again
[Music]
I probably should do an update on this
one I can i let's see what was it
English shift or was that it see if it
goes any faster this time we'll give it
one more shot if that doesn't work then
I don't know then maybe we'll maybe
we'll take a break from trying to get
the mobile version running on this
stream and see if we could do something
else
I kind of want to wrap up soon anyway
though so I think I've hit my hour my
hour limit what I wanted to do so we did
get a little bit accomplished today
let's see
[Music]
[Music]
Valdez you could try running it in the
emulator first then on the phone I
really I want to but I don't have the
the Android emulator installed and I
don't since I'm on a PC I can't I don't
think I can run the iOS I guess I could
try but I'm pretty sure I can't yeah I
need to have Xcode installed which I'm
almost positive you can't run Xcode on
on Windows
hey did it work that time nice
all right let's give this one more shot
let's reopen Expo
oh I think it's working alright clearing
the cache always a good strategy
let's see almost we're 99% 99.5 sweet I
check it out if you can see this that's
our our red background so I'm not I'm
not focused right now so I would need to
actually log in on this device which oh
my gosh that's gonna be a pain let's see
alright so we have it on this device
let's just test out the the vibration
feature just to see if we can get it
working on a device now that we're
actually hooked up so what I want to do
is we've imported vibrate and what I
think I'll do is say like when we press
this button so the button right now runs
in it so let's just use vibration
vibrate and then we could just do in
pattern number we can do a what's the
pattern I'm gonna have to look again I
don't remember exactly what it what it
was
oh here we go oh I remember what what
got us to this anyway is we had we
needed to put something in our Android
file didn't we need to but I don't think
we have it so sore web package and what
was it androidmanifest.xml which I don't
think we even have so let's see if we
can get it to work without that and okay
it looks like we can just put a duration
in just as a number and what is that I'm
assuming that's milliseconds so we got
like 10 seconds here I'm going to save
that
okay cool I think that works I'm gonna
press it cool I'm I don't know if you
can hear that but the phone is vibrating
so our vibration works now unfortunately
we got an error come up which I think we
got the error because we didn't actually
fill in any of the fields so uh so we've
got we got some sort of error but our
vibration works that's really cool so we
can get the device to vibrate so now
it's just a matter of getting the device
to vibrate when the state dips below a
certain a certain amount right so that's
what we want to happen now I'm assuming
with if we actually built something for
Android like to release on you know the
App Store then we would probably get
that Android manifest file since we're
running it through the expo app I think
we don't have to bother with that right
now so we'll just have to remember this
when we go to bundle list I'd love to
actually build this and put it on the
App Store for anybody else who has this
headset to to be able to use so that
would be really cool also YouTube
analytics is telling me the the signal
for my stream is not really good right
now so let me know if you can still see
what's happening on the stream cool
that's really cool now what we need to
do though is let's see we need to figure
out how to set that off based on let's
see hmm
[Music]
let's get rid of that console that keeps
coming up in my my console so you don't
want that so right now it's it's all
based on the state what we could do is
say maybe make a use effect let's make
one down here so let's use use effect
okay so use effect is a react cook that
will allow us to do something anytime a
piece of of data changes and in this
case we're gonna track that focus right
so any time focus changes we're gonna do
a check and we're gonna say if focus
want to keep doing this to me if focus
is greater than whoops I'm gonna say
less than let me say you know point to
yeah you know I was gonna do this as a
ternary but yeah actually we could do it
as a two today we use an if statement
it's a little bit more clear so focus is
great less than point zero point two
then we're going to do vibrate or a
vibration dot vibrate and we'll just do
we'll do 10 seconds else
we're gonna do vibration dot cancel and
cancel it looks like doesn't take
anything as an argument and it returns
void so what this will do is it'll
automatically cancel the vibration when
we regain focus so right now we have
nothing because I didn't log in oh it's
just continuing to vibrate for 10
seconds alright so we got the vibration
so basically we know that works now
which is awesome what we should do
though probably is is say maybe we want
to wrap this entire thing in another if
statement that says if if we're actually
you know login so I guess if notion is
that what we want or do you want to say
user probably user is better so if we
have a user then we want to want to do
this right so we don't want to do this
for login so let's save it and make sure
okay so we say that now we're not
getting a vibration this time that way
that's good to go vibrate let's take out
this vibrate on the on that button press
okay cool and also let's say for the
background color at least for the first
screen I don't know that I really wanted
to start out as red I want it to be
white so we may need to switch that up
as well and maybe say
[Music]
[Music]
if focus is less than 2 or always my or
why can't I find this Oh or we have a
where we don't have user there we go
let's see that fix it up I should say no
I don't want the focus is and we have a
user that's what we need
all right so if the focus is less than
0.2 and we have a user which means like
we're actually logged in then we want it
to be red cool so that changes so you
can see now like the screen is white so
we're not logged in and the screen stays
white so now only if you're logged in
and the focus is less than 0.2 then
it'll be red that's cool the red wasn't
really a good look for the entire
background to be red not that the you
know the application is not like super
good-looking right now but functionally
this is this is basically a complete
application at this point which is
pretty insane so that it only took us 3
3 live streams to do this so I I have
let me let me look this up on my other
screen I am
I'm outlined what I wanted for the basic
MVP meaning Minimum Viable Product for
this project I made a little outline for
myself and I'm going to try to I'm gonna
bring it up on the other screen to make
sure we've met all the requirements so
the requirements were an Android app
that links to notion and alerts when
focus falls below a certain level so
that was it those are the base
requirements so at this point if I could
get this bundled for Android
then that will meet the the MVP and I
think we can we can release that on the
App Store so I think on our next stream
I'd love to actually do the the release
to the App Store if I can
so what I'll need to do beforehand
though is probably do a little bit of
research to make sure I have everything
good on my end I already have an account
with the App Store so I'm good there so
before the next time I stream I'll do
the research for that and then maybe if
you all think it would be you know good
to do I'll try to do like the build and
release to the App Store on the next
stream so I don't know how long it takes
to get approved to go in the App Store
but at least we can do the release there
and just a heads up like the
improvements that I have here in stages
where the step 2 would be release an iOS
version of the app which should be not
that hard because the same version
should work for iOS the only thing I'll
need to do is get an app developer
account for iOS and I may need to do
that release on my on my Mac that build
and release or do some testing on my Mac
and on my PC the next step after that
would be give users the ability to set
the level of focus they want the alert
to come in at which that should be a
pretty easy improvement to add after
that I want to give options for the type
of alert the user wants so I'm thinking
maybe you know do you want vibration do
you want the color to change do you want
maybe some sort of sound after that make
it available for Android auto and that's
kind of clothing that'll that will
actually be very useful to people and
maybe preventing accidents but I've
never done anything when they enter it
auto before in terms of developing so
we'll see how that goes
after that I want to release the web app
version which I get that's not gonna be
hard like we already have it running as
a web app so I could maybe move that up
and and do that a little bit
sooner yeah so I could probably order on
that because that's not gonna be very
difficult especially with without Expo
lets you run it as a web app and you
know get that all up and running I could
probably just release it like github
pages maybe and have that working and
then the last step I had was see if we
can make it into an Alexa app which
that's a big step right so that'll be
you know totally different code but I
thought that might be kind of cool if
you could do an Alexa app that you could
just have that running and connect up so
that's that's my time on my game plan
for and my goals for for the focus it's
been a long time since I've done that
Alette Alexa app so a lot has probably
changed since then
since then I may have to do a little
research on that before we do it but
anyway that's cool I definitely want to
get Android studio running so I can demo
this in the the Android emulator so you
all can see I know it's just super hard
to see it I wonder if I I think the
lights messing it up if it's easy I
think that actually makes it harder but
like here's the app running on my phone
I know it's it's very hard to see so
like just so you could see it actually
isn't running I just need to login the
password and device ID are super long so
that's why I didn't try to login yet but
I am making an assumption that that
actually works on the device I'm
assuming it has at this point but all
right cool so I'm gonna see I'm gonna
take the device off and I'm gonna turn
my device off for now
I'm gonna finish answering some
questions and then finish up I got a
gotta help get two kids to bed too
probably waiting on me so I don't know
if I'll be able to answer all the
questions but I'll do my best and
actually let's let's uh make this let's
send what we have up to github so you
all can check out the code if you want
so we're gonna do a git add give it the
AM flag and the feature let's see where
did we add vibrate on mobile
it'll be Iowa when focus falls below
wait - oh did I mess it up what did I do
oh I did it get get out it needs to be
get commit here we go okay
push sweet all right so that code should
be on github now the link to the github
repo is in the description so you can
check out that code if you want
I saw a few you already look like you
checked you it you checked it out like
forked it and started and stuff so you
know definitely feel free to open any
issues or anything with that code or a
pull request if you see something that's
like that you would like to contribute
or some obvious problem with the code
definitely I'm always open to to new
suggestions and open to collaborate on
things I'm gonna try to find where I
left off in the chat
[Music]
all right so ty Cordy says what's the
interface between your brain and the
device how do you control it the its I'm
assuming it's the you're talking about
this notion headset for now for what
we're doing we it just tracks the gamma
waves that your brain is is putting off
and that tells you your level of focus
there's a lot other cool stuff we can do
with it which we will do I hope to make
other apps that will allow you to think
of doing an action and then make things
happen in the app or on other internet
of things devices so I hope to make that
happen
this is kind of my first idea for an app
if I can get this working imma move on
to more challenging things maybe some
some more fun stuff
see
okay Beverly says we had a question
earlier about a Python question about
whether an API and a module were like
Python modules Beverly says that modules
in Python are more equivalent to
libraries so that's what I thought but I
wasn't you know obviously I don't have
enough experience with Python to really
say for sure so I didn't want to say
anything but yeah it's so in in Python
lingo I guess we would modules are what
we would call libraries in JavaScript
[Music]
okay tyke or D is like I would like to
learn more about your project like
papers etc I would like to make a thesis
on brain computer interfaces could you
help okay um I would check out check out
the neuro city website
it's neuro city dot let me let me put
the link in the chat
it's neuro City dot Co
and see if you can get like the contact
info or Twitter or something I'm putting
that in a chat right now contact the
people at neuro city and see if they
have any more data for you because you
know they're the ones that are really
working on the brain computer interface
side of things and will have way more
knowledge than I will about it they
might be able to help you out with more
the technical info Ruben says react
native or flutter we had a question like
this on the last stream I have not used
flutters so I don't think I can give a
good a good answer to that question okay
so I mean I use react native it works
for what what I do but maybe for you
know for other teams with different
skill sets you know maybe maybe flutter
would be the better choice I'm just not
sure
[Music]
well yeah everybody's kind of calling
out where they're from so we had
Baltimore calli Indianapolis hungry we
were talking about Jim's earlier and mr.
Coldwater Canyon says Jim's aren't all
that sanitary yeah I imagine they're not
you know you got a bunch of people
sweating and stuff on the machines so
yeah probably not the best place to be
you know during a virus outbreak
[Music]
that Valve dark says how do you narrow
down what you're meant to be focusing on
just focus in general seems a bit vague
to be useful yeah I'm like I said I'm
not sure what the science is in terms of
how the brain operates but Alex who was
one of the creators of the neuro City
notion headset said the the gamma waves
are an indicator of the level of focus
your brain has so I don't know that it's
a specific focus like you could tell
exactly what you were focusing on but
it's more a general level of focus so
yeah I I mean I'd love to see when you
know get this up and running and really
test it out on a variety of different
things that I'm doing and see you know
how it works if it is specific enough to
be useful you know or not yet someone
says I need to learn this I'm using
Cordova to build web apps and run them
on Android
yeah I'm messing around with Cordova a
little bit back in the day
I do find react natives to be a bit
easier but I I do use react a lot so it
is easier for me if if you didn't know
that much about react then Cordova might
be a little easier to go but in general
I think like I haven't used any of the
newer versions of Cordova but in general
I believe that react native is kind of a
better way to go for most use cases
[Music]
see veil dog says okay this is a good
point basically the point is you know if
you're driving and you're trying to
measure focus so you should be driving
on the road what if you have a lot of
focus on something else instead of
driving the app would still you know
would the app still register that is
focus and not warn you I don't know I
really need to test that so a lot of
this stuff I've kind of wondered about
as well like will this really provide a
you know good thing in terms of focus so
I in terms of like measuring what you
really want to focus on so I just need
to test it out and see how useful it is
by the question what should this app do
after it is finished it should warn you
whenever your levels of focus have
dropped below a certain threshold
see Scott says vs code update available
I know there's there's an update
available I usually stay updated you
know like every time it comes up but the
last two days I've opened up vs code
right before the live stream and I
didn't want to do the update then
because I needed the stream so I just
put it off till later we got high from
Australia high from India awesome Carlos
is there any way to develop django web
applications with a 32-bit architecture
system I have no idea I've never done
anything with Django so so I don't know
if anybody knows anything about Django
please let us know in the chat
[Music]
says hello from Bangladesh awesome
welcome Kevin Kevin has said the hello
from so many different places in the
chat much sure where Kevin is really
from at this point greetings from Poland
how's it going all right cool I am oh
Carlos si from Venezuela awesome hey I'm
gonna wrap this up so I've gone over by
30 minutes but what I wanted to go over
so I definitely got to get help the kids
get ready for bed at this point thank
you all so much for watching I'm really
excited
you know we pretty much we have this
working the next step is just to build
it and release it to the App Store
probably want to make it look a little
bit nicer first the UI is not not great
at this point so maybe we'll work on
that as well for the next stream but it
was a good stream I am a lot of
troubleshooting just remember if if
you're Metro bundler is not working
correctly try clearing the cache and
that should work that that worked for us
and it's worked for me in the past as
well now that I think about it
that's always a good thing to try so I
don't know when I'll stream again
tomorrow will be a little bit busier
I'll be back to work
but I I want to try to at the very least
maybe stream you know at the latest some
point you know next week next weekend
hopefully I can get a stream in there
before then though because I'm getting
really excited because we're really
close to actually launching this app
which that'll be fun it would be my
first app that I've actually decided to
put on the App Store I usually never get
to that point I just build something and
play with it a little bit and then just
don't do anything with it
so anyway everyone you know everybody be
safe out there don't take any
unnecessary risks you know try to help
each other out I know you know some
depending on where you're from
you know things are pretty rough right
now but thanks for joining me and stay
safe I know a lot of people at home so
I'm gonna do my best to try to stream a
little bit more and maybe it'll make
things a little bit easier for everybody
that's the stuck at home
yeah but until next time have a great
rest of your weekend
have a great week and I'll see you later